people often say that they think they
have there why well more than that that
they feel it that it feels right and
they know they're in the ballpark but
they're struggling to find the words
that's okay the most important part
about this why process is that indeed it
feels right remember the Y exists in the
part of the brain the limbic brain that
controls our feelings it also controls
all our behavior and decision-making and
so we don't want to think that it's
right we want to feel that it's right
and once you have that gut decision that
that that's it and and you get
goosebumps when you start telling the
stories that you think push you in
towards your why then you know you had
it if you start to well up or have an
emotional response you definitely know
you're in the ballpark then the trick is
to find the words and it's the words
it's the ability to articulate your why
that makes it actionable and so
absolutely the why the the words will
evolve the words will adapt and change
but the meaning cannot it's the meaning
of those words those words that give you
that visceral feeling those goosebumps
that make you well up whatever the
feeling you had is that's what's
paramount but the words you can tweak
and change absolutely for the end of
time I've tweaked my wide multiple times
over the years but the meaning of it in
the basic direction is still exactly the
same it's like a submarine when the
captain orders the submarine to go north
the submarine doesn't go in a straight
line it kind of goes like this and
you're why is the same thing you need to
know the direction it's heading but it's
okay if it goes like this as you're
tweaking the words as long as you're
moving in the right direction